we have a voicemail number.
That number is two one nine two David P..
I received many voicemails and questions that
are very similar to this, asking whether the
riot may not be a pretext for Trump to declare
martial law.
OK, let's take a listen.
OK.
The problem is that I'm just watching the
Trump people attacking the Congress, and then
it seems wrong that the left is playing into
their hands by actually making a big deal,
because then it would give the Trump people
the chance to call for martial law.
Yeah.
So this was brought up a lot during my live
streams yesterday.
Trump incites a riot, sends in the National
Guard.
Things are or doesn't as yet, it seems.
He refused to, but Mike Pence did.
But in any case, uses the riots to say we
need to declare martial law and I'm going
to stay in office.
I don't think Trump is that organized.
And what we've seen in the last 12 hours,
not in the last 24, but in the last 12, is
that Donald Trump has finally put out a statement
saying he's going to leave peacefully on January
20th.
It's too late for it to be peaceful, but at
least he's saying on the 20th he will be peaceful.
We have seen the riots largely quelled and
it is not what is going to take place now.
I did also receive messages from people saying,
should the left really be saying we need more
of a law enforcement presence on the capital
when law enforcement is is often the problem,
not a law enforcement presence was needed
on the Capitol yesterday.
There's just no where.
How do you quell what was going on without
a law enforcement presence?
And I think that the relatively few leftists
who were saying that were were simply were
simply maybe just not thinking about it in
the right way.
But I don't blame you for wondering, would
Trump incite a riot to then create the pretext
in which he would declare martial law?
I think morally he would have no problem with
it.
I think the limitations are he's not that
organized and he's already said, I'm leaving.
And the riots have calmed down.
Now, there are rumors that there are going
to be more riots today and even in the days
leading up to January 20th, we will pay attention
to that and we will cover it if if it should
come to pass.
We will be discussing on the bonus show today.
There have been some videos which purport
to be police actually removing barricades
to let protesters, rioters in yesterday to
the U.S. Capitol.
We're going to talk about that because there
are a number of perspectives about those supposed
videos.
We will also talk about in the midst of this.
Joe Biden is actually getting some sweet revenge
in that Merrick Garland will be his attorney
general, Merrick Garland, Barack Obama's Supreme
Court nominee, who was obstructed by Mitch
McConnell and Republicans back in 2016.
And much more on today's bonus show.
I very quickly, I so appreciate the couple
hundred people that grabbed the memberships
over the last 48 hours in appreciation of
the coverage we've been doing.
I really appreciate it.
I invite you to grab a membership at Join
Pakman Dotcom.